today's video is brought to you by
nordvpn a VPN service that not only
allows you to browse the internet
privately and securely but comes with
plenty of extras and features more on
them later there has been spirited
debate among historians over which of
the 46 presidents of the United States
ranks as the best there has also been
spirited though somewhat more subdued
debate over which of them was the worst
and boy have there been some bad ones
from James Buchanan who essentially sat
on his hands and watched as the nation
tore itself apart and triggered the
Civil War to Warren G Harding who
famously presided over one of the most
corrupt administrations in history but
no debate about worse presidents of all
time would be complete without
mentioning John Tyler the 10th President
Tyler was never supposed to be president
he assumed the office following the
sudden death of his predecessor the
first time that had happened in American
history it was just the first of a
string of unprecedented events that
would shape American politics for a
generation among other things Tyler
successfully derailed the legislative
agenda of his own party causing them to
expel him from their ranks his
obstinence irritated almost everyone in
Washington to the point that he had few
friends and entirely too many enemies he
even most important achievement during
his presidency adding taxes to the union
ultimately triggered a war that caused
the deaths of tens of thousands and set
the stage for an even more destructive
War a decade later and if that weren't
bad enough John Tyler managed to ruin
his reputation even further at the end
of his life when he advocated for
succession and I was elected to the
Confederate Congress causing many to
view him as a traitor when he died it
was accorded almost none of the honors
usually given to a former president and
the historical outlook on his life and
career has hardly been rehabilitated by
the passage of time
foreign
ER was born on March 29 1790 in the
Tidewater region of Southeastern
Virginia the tilas were one of the
wealthiest families in the state tracing
their Roots back to the colonial times
and had a long history of Public Service
Tyler's Father John Senior known as
judge Tyler was no exception enjoying a
distinguished political career that
included a close friendship with Thomas
Jefferson and election as governor of
Virginia in 1808. from the start John
Tyler was raised to become everything
his father was a lawyer a future
politician and above all a perfect
Southern gentleman concerned with his
standing in society and his honor at all
times like many boys John loved his
father and wanted to make him proud so
he studied hard graduating from the
College of William and Mary in
Williamsburg in 1807 when he was 17. he
passed the bar and became a lawyer at 19
technically two years too young to sit
the exam but it seems the examiner
simply hadn't bothered to find out how
old he was he began practicing as a
lawyer in Richmond and he was good at it
but his real passion was politics in
fact the only reason he became a lawyer
in the first place was because it was
seen as a necessary prerequisite to
becoming a politician politics would
become the defining love of Tyler's life
one that he was far more passionate
about than his wife Leticia who he
married in 1813. that was more about
fulfilling the southern gentleman's
obligation to marry well and produce
children than any sense of romance and
produce they did eight of them between
1815 and 1830. Tyler's first taste of
politics came in 1811 when he was
elected to the Virginia House of
delegates serving there for five years
in 1816 he seized an opportunity to get
himself elected to the United States
House of Representatives and would
thereafter spend half the year in
Washington DC tending to the people's
business which caused an unfortunate
drop in the revenues of his own business
it was difficult to maintain a thriving
legal practice at home when he spent so
much time away and revenues at his
Plantation suffered when he wasn't there
personally supervising it Tyler would
spend much of his life in debt relying
on borrowing money from friends and from
the bank to keep himself afloat in
Congress Tyler became more well known
for what he opposed than what he
supported almost from the moment of its
founding there had been an argument
about which entity should have more
power in the United States the federal
government or the individual states that
divided up the country Tyler came down
firmly on the side of state's rights and
in this like with most everything else
he emulated his father judge Tyler had
tried unsuccessfully to prevent Virginia
from ratifying the Constitution back in
1787 and when that failed he became what
was known as a constructionist
constructionists believed that the
federal government can't do anything
that isn't explicitly permitted to them
by the Constitution their opponents
variously known as the consolidationists
or centralists believed that the federal
government can do anything that isn't
specifically prohibited by the
Constitution these two arguments have
dominated American politics for almost
250 years and will likely keep doing so
into the future
[Music]
foreign
ER as a believer in states rights and
constructionism spent most of his time
in Congress opposing bills he believed
were unconstitutional at the top of his
list was Central Banking Alexander
Hamilton's First Bank of the United
States had been dissolved when its
Charter expired in 1811 but President
James Madison a vocal critic of the bank
found himself facing an economic crisis
in the aftermath of the War of 1812 and
realized a second bank would have to be
chartered to manage the nation's money
when John Tyler and other Southern
lawmakers attacked the bank as
unconstitutional it's important to keep
in mind that the reason they were so
opposed to it was because Central
Banking tended to favor the Commerce
class like businesses and manufacturers
most of whom were concentrated in the
north it didn't benefit the planter
class that dominated the Southern
economy because their wealth was
concentrated in assets primarily land
and slaves as opposed to cash and John
Tyler was absolutely one of the planter
class he maintained a number of farms
and plantations throughout his life all
of which were operated using slave labor
he saw no reason why thing change and
why would he the present system already
rewarded him as a result most of his
constitutional stands were made just as
much out of self-interest as from
ideological Purity however it was four
ideological Purity that he became famous
as a politician not only as part of a
House of Representatives but also
through two more stints in the Virginia
House of delegates a two-year term as
Governor and as a U.S senator from 1827
to 1836. he became known as a man of
principle someone who stuck to his
State's rights beliefs no matter what
this was epitomized in 1836 when he
resigned from The Cellar following a
dispute with President Andrew Jackson
but while he was making a name for
himself in Washington his home life
suffered his frequent absences continued
to play havoc on his finances and his
children largely grew up without him
frequently communicating with their
father only through letters as for his
wife her many pregnancies left her in
ill health she was frequently bedridden
especially after 1839 when she suffered
a stroke she also suffered from what
19th century doctor is called hysteria
which was frequently triggered by her
husband's impending departure from home
for their Capital Tyler himself was
often ill plagued with stomach ailments
and other diseases some medical
historians have guessed that he suffered
from Guillain-Barre syndrome and
autoimmune disorder less is known about
water Letitia since diseases of the Mind
tended to be kept private back then to
avoid a scandal but the most common
guess is severe depression then we're
going to talk about a common cyber
threat that you may not be fully aware
of DDOS attacks or distributed denial of
service attacks occur or when a hacker
floods a website or online service with
traffic making it unavailable to
legitimate users these types of attacks
can be incredibly disruptive causing
website downtime and lost revenue for
businesses but did you know that you can
become the victim of a DDOS attack just
by clicking on a link in an email or on
Twitch or in a Discord chat once the
attacker has your IP address they can
launch a DDOS attack and disrupt your
internet service so how can you protect
yourself from one of these attacks well
an effective solution to this is nordvpn
nordvn is more more than just a VPN it
also has a threat protection function
that protects you from ads track is
malware with nordvpn you can use the
internet safely and securely without
having to worry about DDOS attacks or
any other cyber threats in fact nor VPN
can even protect you from dos attacks by
hiding your IP address if a person
attempts to DDOS the VPN address nor VPN
servers will handle the attack and
you'll experience no disruptions to your
service but that's an all-nored VPN has
to offer you can use nordvpn on up to
six devices on all major platforms
including Windows Mac Linux Android and
iOS nordvpn also allows you to bypass
geographical restrictions so you can
access content from anywhere in the
world and with their 30-day money-back
guarantee you could try nordvpn
risk-free so check out norvpn and get an
exclusive deal by going to nordvpn.com
forward slash bio protect yourself from
DDOS attacks and other cyber threats
today with nordvpn thanks for listening
and now back to today's video
[Music]
in 1840 John Tyler's political career
seemed to be over after his resignation
in 1836 had broken with Andrew Jackson's
Democratic party which had caused him to
gravitate to their opponents the wings
but Tyler didn't like much of the weak
platform either which was dominated by
Senator Henry Clay of Kentucky clay
considered one of the 19th Century's
most brilliant politicians was the
champion of centralization having been
an architect of the Second Bank of the
United States and when Andrew Jackson
successfully killed it in 1836 clay
vowed that he would start another one
1840 was the great chance for the Whigs
to seize power and make Clay's dreams a
reality the country had been gripped by
an economic depression since 1837 and
many blamed Democratic president Martin
Van Buren and his party's fiscal policy
for it at the party's nomination
convention in Harrisburg the Whigs
eventually settled on General William
Henry Harrison as their candidate for
president but who would be his running
mate nobody seemed to want the job of
being vice president and it isn't hard
to see why it was considered a political
dead end in those days VPS had little to
do besides preside over the Senate and
they only voted in that body when there
was a tie to break and it wasn't seen as
a natural stepping stone for the
presidency either between 1800 and 1968
only one man who had previously served
as vice president had been elected
president in his own right after several
verbal candidates turned them down the
Whigs turned to Tyler who accepted and
the ticket was complete the weeks won
big in the 1840 election backs of Tippy
Canoe and Tyler too a popular campaign
slogan that referred to General
Harrison's famous victory in the Battle
of Tippecanoe in 1811. not only did they
win the White House but they swept
majorities in both houses of Congress as
well Henry Clay believed he had a
mandate from the American people to
enact his legislative agenda and nothing
appeared to stand in his way but they
was about to change the course of
American history on the 4th of April
1841 only a month after being sworn in
his vice president John Tyler woke up to
a knock on his door in the middle of the
night the news he received was grave
president Harrison was dead at the
victim of pneumonia he was needed in
Washington immediately this was the
first time that the Constitutional line
of succession needed to be used and it
immediately provoked confusion no one
was sure if John Tyler assumed the
office of President upon the death of
William Henry Harrison or if he remained
vice president and merely assumed the
duties of President until a new one
could be elected constitutional
confusion was averted when Tyler himself
decided that he was now the president he
took the oath of office the next day and
for the rest of his life he would return
all mail that addressed him as Vice
President Tyler or acting President
Tyler unopened this set a precedence in
the seven subsequent cases where a
president died and off as the vice
president has taken over after taking
the oath of office the line of
succession was eventually clarified with
ratification of the 25th Amendment to
the Constitution in 1967. still it
wasn't all smooth sailing for John Tyler
for the rest of his term his opponents
derided him as his accident see because
of the way that it assumed the office
foreign
er's presidency was largely defined by
what happened in those first few months
after he assumed the office in September
of 1841 a special session of Congress
was called to address the ongoing
financial crisis twice during that
session Henry Clay and the Whigs passed
bills to create a national bank that
they believed was needed to write the
economic ship and twice they were
stymied when President Tyler vetoed the
bill as a result nothing was done and
the Whigs looked impotent this enraged
clay whose electoral Landslide was now
falling to pieces all around him but in
hindsight it hardly seemed surprising
since Tyler had always been opposed to a
central bank the real question is why
the wigs would have risked putting him
on the ticket in the first place
Harrison was 68 years old an old man by
19th century standards there was always
a risk of him dying in office it seems
the only answer to this is that nobody
thought of it as a possibility eight
presidents had come and gone before
Harris and all of whom completed their
terms without issue whatever the reason
for putting him on the ticket the Whigs
surely regretted doing so now now and
they took their wrath out on John Tyler
by ejecting him from the party in the
fall of 1841 leaving him as a president
without a party the entire cabinet Tyler
had inherited from Harrison resigned
except the Secretary of State Daniel
Webster Tyler had few friends in
Washington the Whigs now hated him and
the Democrats though they were delighted
to see their opponent's agenda shredded
like this weren't willing to accept him
into their ranks either not with Andrew
Jackson still as their leader Tyler
would go up against the wigs again in
1842. this time over the issue of
tariffs with federal income tax still
decades away import duties one of the
only ways that the federal government
made money once again the issue split on
sectional lines northern states favored
High tariffs as it Protected Their
industries from European competition
while Southern States hated them because
it impeded their exports of cotton to
attack star Mills of Great Britain Tyler
as a southerner favored free trade but
like many idealists that find themselves
in positions of executive power he
discovered that in order to actually run
the country he needed to raise tariffs
not lower them the federal government
was running out of money in 1842 there
was a real risk of the United States
being unable to pay its bills still for
months Tyler battled Congress over how
much the tariffs should be raised
whether it should be a temporary or
permanent measurement over the fate of
distribution an emergency program that
gave the profits from federal land sales
to the state so that they could pay off
their own debts he vetoed two more bills
that summer before an agreement that
satisfied nobody was finally worked out
his Bridges with the Whigs were now well
and truly burned and Henry Clay resigned
from the Senate everyone knew it was to
prepare for his run for presidency in
1844. there was even talk of impeaching
the president for the first time in
history though grounds to do so were
never found
thank you
compounding Tyler's misery during this
period was the death of Leticia Tyler's
wife passed away in 1842 following a
second stroke one of three first ladies
to die while her husband was in office
for the second time in two years the
White House was in mourning the Tyler
administration's only major success
during this period was ratification of
the Webster ashburton treaty with Great
Britain which settled a long-running
border dispute between the state of
Maine and the Canadian province of New
Brunswick as oel is fixing the modern
border between Minnesota and Ontario but
that was basically it Tyler it seemed
had no real policy platform of his own
to offer up everyone knew what he was
against but what was he actually for
Tyler himself didn't seem to know most
of the time he irritated even his
closest Associates with his tendency to
Waffle back and forth on various issues
changing his mind multiple times and
confusing everyone around him by the end
of 1843 however Tyler believed he'd
figured out an issue that would cement
his legacy as president and might even
boost his third party run for
re-election the annexation of Texas
since 1836 the Republic of Texas had
operated as an independent country
following its victory in the Texas
Revolution over Mexico but all along Sam
Houston the Texan leadership had been
trying to convince the American
government to Annex them both the
Jackson and Van Buren administrations
had ignored them worried that doing so
would spark war with Mexico but Tyler a
firm believer in Manifest Destiny saw
taxes as a potentially valuable part of
the union and didn't think the Mexicans
oh would risk a war to stop the U.S from
taking over he had taxed his fever and
set as Secretary of State
ayabal option to oh work on making the
annexation happen he faced an upper
battle in Congress though with the issue
of Texas lying not only on party lines
but sectional ones as well the addition
of Texas as a slave state would upset
the delicate balance of power kept
between slave states and free States
since the Missouri Compromise of 1820
and northern states weren't Keen to see
the slave power again an even more
dominant position in National politics
than they already had still in the first
two months of 1844 it seemed like the
administration had enough support for
annexation in the Senate and a treaty
always being worked out with the Texans
then disaster struck on February 28 1844
President Tyler members of his cabinet
and hundreds of other guests took a
ceremonial cruise down the Potomac River
on board the USS Princeton a newly built
U.S Navy Corvette the ship's Captain
Robert F Stockton took great pleasure in
test firing a 27 000 pound Naval Cannon
nicknamed Peacemaker for his guests the
gun was fired twice without instant but
when Stockton pulled the lanyard the
third time the gun barrel exploded
showering the deck with deadly shrapnel
six men were killed including two
members of dialer's cabinet Secretary of
State Upshaw and Secretary of the Navy
Thomas Gilmer fortunately for Tyler he
was below decks when the accident
occurred had he been killed history
would have looked very different as
without a vice president to replace in
the president pro tempore at the Senate
one of Henry Clay's allies would have
become president also killed in the
explosion was David Gardner a prominent
New York attorney and friend of
president
daughter Julia had been carrying on a
prolonged courtship with the president
for over a year despite the fact that
Tyler was 30 years older than she was
oddly enough the death of her father
provided that push Julia Gardiner needed
to finally agree to marry Tyler after
rejecting him twice and they were wed
four months later the first presidential
wedding in American history
[Music]
the death of secretary Upshaw the lead
negotiator on the Texas treaty
complicated matters immensely his
replacement John C Calhoun owas are one
of the most famous pro-slavery
politicians in the country and he
created a scandal when he wrote in a
letter to a British Minister that the
reason the U.S was annexing Texas was to
protect slavery from British
interference as a result abolitionists
Whigs and anyone who feared war with
Mexico all came out against annexation
the Senate rejected his treaty in April
the election of 1844 turned into a
referendum on annexation with no chance
of being elected himself Tyler decided
to play spoiler forcing other Democrats
to nominate a pro-annexation candidate
James K Polk in exchange for dropping
out of the race himself this maneuver
foiled Tyler's adversary Henry Clay one
more time as he was defeated by Polk in
the election instead of a treaty Tyler
ensured Texas's place in the Union by a
joint resolution of Congress inviting
them to join which was signed by the
president on his last day in office
March 3rd 1845. a speared the annexation
of Texas sparked conflict the
Mexican-American War would last two
years and claim some 40 000 lives as
part of the treaty negotiations Mexico
ceded to the U.S not only Texas but a
huge swath of territory in the southwest
which would become four new States the
addition of so much new territory also
inadvertently set the north and south on
a collision course with each other that
would end a decade later with Civil War
this mostly seemed beyond the concern of
John Tyler though after leaving office
he retired to a new Plantation in
Virginia that he named Sherwood Forest
he largely withdrew from politics
preferring the life of a gentleman
farmer overseeing some 70 slaves as they
grew wheat and corn for him his life
with the second wife was certainly much
happier than with his first everyone who
met the tile has indicated how much John
and Julia loved each other despite their
dramatic age difference they also had a
bunch more children seven in all for a
total of 15 between two wives the most
of any president the last of his
children Pearl was born in 1860 when
John was 70 years old this unusual
circumstance combined with the similar
proclivity on the part of one of his
younger children Leon is the reason why
John Tyler is the oldest former
president to still have a living
grandchild Harrison Ruffin Tyler age 94.
Tyler probably should have stayed out of
the secession crisis that swept through
the south in the aftermath of Abraham
Lincoln's election in 1860. it wasn't
like he could help himself though his
addiction to politics rearing its head
even in old age it probably shouldn't be
surprising that Tyler always the only
one out of the five living former
presidents that took the side of the
Confederacy when civil war broke out
considering that he was the only one of
five that was from the south and also a
slave holder but he went beyond just
supporting the South he actively called
for Virginia's secession and I was
elected to the Confederate House of
Representatives doing this and in the
Wanaka traitor president in the north
ruining forever what was already a bad
reputation before he could take his seat
in the rebel Congress however Tyler
became ill his persistent ill health had
finally caught up to him and he died on
January 18 1862. his death was only
acknowledged in the southern states
Lincoln's Administration gave Tyler none
of the Honors that would have been
expected for a former president the
northern press basically ignored his
death or reported on it perfunctorally
without tribute or emotion he was buried
in Richmond's Hollywood Cemetery today
John Tyler has been largely forgotten by
the American public just another 19th
century president's name to memorize an
elementary school and then forget about
for a man who was obsessed with his
presidential Legacy who spent nearly his
entire post-presidential life defending
what he'd done from 1841 to 1845 to be
relegated to American ignomy would
probably be the ultimate insult even the
south in the years after the Civil War
tried to forget about Tyler since a
slave holding former president undercut
their adherence to the Lost Cause
rhetoric that was embraced by Southern
historians at the end of the 19th
century some people would argue that
that's just what he deserves that a man
who couldn't see past his own personal
principles for the good of the country
and defended the South and the practice
of slavery even to the point of War
shouldn't be remembered fondly in life
John Tyler owes a president without a
party today he's arguably something
worse a president without a legacy or at
least not a good Legacy